I realized this week that I need to
build a tremendous legal team to help me
with this investigation that I'm totally
not under wink it's time for lawyer ring
up oh yeah
shake your hand but I don't want to get
to say look for touching you
inappropriately you would be I'm in a
bit of trouble Toby I'm not going to lie
so I understand I am auditioning lawyers
to be on my dancing first off how do we
are you on the scale of one to Jairus
are you like a four or five because we
all know Jewish lawyers are the best
I'm very jewy and not very good I don't
even understand that question okay there
we go
a coy Jew now you've defended
con-artists foreign agents and monsters
but have you ever done all three this
would be my first if I took the case
triple Lindy yeah if I hired you would I
be your favorite client first of all
you'd be second - okay Simpson on the
gun Klaus von Bulow right guys no Mike
Tyson and Bill Clinton Bill Clinton uh I
don't think that you remember me I have
a lawsuit against you what on behalf of
Sommers their votes who is one of the
women during the presidential campaign
well is this the way the interview is
going who'd accused you of actually
doing some of the things that you said I
have did on that Access Hollywood tape
you're out of order
where you alleged you could grab a woman
by I'm not going to use the word that
you said genitals and then you said
they're Liars a liar's and i filed a
lawsuit against you which is now pending
in New York City that's the kind of
lawyer I want I can't that's a conflict
you centered yeah law school did and
then you were a professor at Harvard
what you think you're better than me
absolutely I have no doubt that I'm
better
you know at the University of
Pennsylvania's work for throat
embittered rank I went to work I went to
Yale Law School
number one win the school Harvey I was
going I am you much been discussed if
you want a lawyer that's better than you
feel you want a lawyer that's worse than
you yes we're attorney-client privilege
now we go alright we're going to admit
some things too I'm going to tell
everybody everything you said anything
you tell me is completely confidential
I can tell you anything I have a small
heart attack four times a day I think
about Jeff Sessions in a bikini all the
time yeah I have Rue McClanahan brain in
a jar
are you sure these are things that I
should know I want to hunt and eat a
male ballerina I masturbate with both
hands who doesn't Alan
am I being investigated or not you are
being investigated ish the cookie is
making your life yes they abyssal
edition geisha nothing but yeah yeah not
quite investigated not quite not
investigated but let's face it around
the White House its Michigan
maybe if I become your lawyer will you
actually do the things I suggest you do
now will you stop doing the things I
suggest you stop doing no thank you for
that what is my biggest legal problem
did you ever hear these words
obstruction of justice
no I haven't heard them till you said
them can I sue James Comey if you tried
to get him to stop investigating you I
didn't do it that's potentially
obstruction of justice
ding-ding-ding Jonathan impeachable
offense you can't handle the truth
don't know where I'm coming from I'm
crazy like a fox because it makes your
job is you know it makes my job better
because if you get yourself indicted or
impeached I have a real job and you are
helping me enormous Lee everything you
say everything you do makes it more
likely you gonna get in
teach resign now while there's still
time do you think you can keep me out of
jail if you do what I tell you to do I
can keep you out of prison I'm not sure
at this point that that I want to you
know sometimes there's a lot I'd like to
do with you and Olivia to do it's all
legal though it might all angle really
heal is it oh boy
Gloria don't do this to me you are so
disgusting
Thank You lawyer let me tell you
something I wish I can have you on my
legal team but you just didn't represent
yourself with a knowledge of the body of
the law that's needed unfortunately you
haven't passed the interview
and your fire so big so I think you're
smart to ultimately a dirty hippie I
have to go with my gut you're fired
alan dershowitz unfortunately you're too
Jewish even for me your fire so I'm
going to have to go to my back pocket
for my trump card Gilbert Godfrey you
are my world
Donald I told you I'm not really a
lawyer
[Applause]